لقد كتبت كتابًا عن القيادة ،
لذا دعنا نتحدث عن زعيم
الولايات المتحدة ، نعم جو بايدن ، كيف
تعتقد أنه
لا يفعل ذلك جيدًا كما يجب أن يكون أه
هو من وجهة نظري في
وقت مبكر اعتقدت أنه سيكون كذلك
قائد مهم للغاية لأنني
اعتقدت أن التعاطف الذي
كان لديه فهمه والقوة الداخلية
التي تأتي من التعامل
مع النكسات ولحظات البوتقة
التي مر بها في الحياة ،
اعتقدت أنهم سيسرقونه من أجل
الرئاسة.
وأنت تعلم أنه فعل بعض الأشياء بشكل صحيح ،
أعتقد أن قلبه لا يزال في المكان المناسب ،
لكن من الصعب بشكل متزايد معرفة
ما هي الأهداف هنا
التي يحتاجون إليها لتقليص هذا إلى هدفين أو
ثلاثة أهداف رئيسية والاستمرار في تحقيق ذلك.
إنجازاته في كل من
السياسة الخارجية والسياسة المحلية ،
هذا هو اللغز حول بايدن ، العديد من
سياساته تحظى بشعبية ولكن لديه هو نفسه
معدلات قبول منخفضة بشكل مذهل ،
هل تفهم
أنني لا أفهم ذلك  لا أفهم ذلك تمامًا ،
أعتقد أن الرسائل لم
تكن مصدر قوته ، وأن الذهاب
أمام الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم كثيرًا ما يكون لديه
ما يقوله ولكنه يضعه
في الساعة الرابعة بعد الظهر
إذا كنت قد حصلت بالفعل  شيء مهم
للتحدث مع الأمريكيين حول القيام
بذلك في وقت الذروة ، تعلمون أنه يمكننا التعامل مع
15 دقيقة و 20 دقيقة ،
ودور القائد هو أن يكون معلمًا
وهذا جزء مهم من
الذي تعرفه
اعتاد fdr  جادل بأن القيادة الأخلاقية تدور
حول قيام الرئيس بالاختيارات
ومحاولة جلب الناس إلى جانب
القضايا الصعبة
، ولم يكن هناك الكثير من ذلك ، وما
زلت أفكر به كثيرًا
كفرد ،
لكنني أقترح أيضًا
أنني قلق بشأن فكرة  أعني بايدن
مقابل ترامب في عام 2024
عندما كان كلا الرجلين في الثمانينيات من العمر ،
لم نكن هناك من قبل
ولا أعتقد أن هذا أمر صحي ،
فالرئاسة
معقدة للغاية ولا
تتطلب حكمًا جيدًا ، فأنت لا تحصل إلا على
المكالمات الصعبة التي تحصل عليها  5  4 5248 مكالمات
تعرف أن أسهلها يتم تحديدها في مكان
آخر